tomorrow is the 17th anniversary of the
September 11th attacks and Americans are
commemorating and rebuilding what was
lost on that day in 2001 a subway
station in lower Manhattan that was
buried in World Trade Center debris
finally reopened over the weekend and
near Shanksville Pennsylvania the Tower
of voices was dedicated Sunday it is the
final piece of the flight 93 National
Memorial chip Reid is on the grounds of
the memorial where he attended that
ceremony chip good morning
well good morning that is the tower of
voices directly behind me it is 93 feet
tall in honor of flight 93 and it is
essentially a very large musical
instrument intended to recall the voices
of the 40 people who died here
[Music]
in Shanksville Pennsylvania Sunday this
rain soaked but stalwart crowd refused
to allow the elements to interfere with
a ceremony honoring the heroes of flight
93
I hope the words that we express today
are as powerful a tribute to the heroes
and heroines as your presence in this
weather on September 11th 2001
Tom Ridge then the governor of
Pennsylvania rushed to the crash site
the sound at the moment took my breath
away it was louder than the army Chinook
helicopter they brought me here it was
the brutal and I think sometimes
unbearable sound of silence the silence
of this pastoral and somber place will
now forever have a new sound the music
of wind chimes soon there will be forty
installed here to symbolize the voices
of the 40 who died those voices were
immortalized in phone calls and
voicemails left by the passengers and
crew before the plane went down we don't
look at the 40 passengers and crews as
victims we look at them as heroes before
the rain fell we talked to Gordon felt
president of the families of flight 93
his brother Edie felt was a passenger on
the plane obviously they wanted to live
but they also knew that in order to to
try to survive they had a fight and in
doing so they they lost their lives but
they averted a far greater tragedy that
tragedy was the destruction of the US
Capitol which is believed to have been
the target of the hijackers what does
the tower of voices add to this memorial
well for me the tower voices is a symbol
of defiance 93 feet tall standing at the
entrance to this memorial defiantly
speaking for our loved ones
Paul Murdock is the architect of the
flight 93 memorial it's a monumental
piece
it's meant to be heroic this is a
battleground on the one hand but it's
also a final resting place of these 40
people okay here we go there will be
another ceremony here tomorrow on the
anniversary of 9/11 President Trump and
the first lady are expected to attend
Nora Jeb thank you so much you know I
just was at the 9/11 museum here in New
York on Friday and the the stories are
so important to be told about what what
happened then the lives lost because
even today we have all of the law
enforcement first responders all
suffering the after-effects some of them
with cancer they still need to be taken
care of as well yes right people will be
thinking about this day and how we came
together in the aftermath of that as we
looked at the landscape today it's
important to just take a step back and
breathe that's right and although all
the heroes and particularly on flight 93
Todd Beamer and the others who rushed
the cockpit so that it wouldn't hit I
mean that amazing courage in that moment
is extraordinary saved the Capitol